Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to SCP Containment Breach
I dont know if you guys remember what happens to this particular SCP
uh it's it's a little interesting
I'm gonna actually do it so that you guys can see it before anything but um
the thing about this particular SCP is a-
AhhHhhh
*jumpscare sound* IYEE
OH NOOO
am I dead? (yes)
Did I die? (yep)
Have I expired? (pretty sure)
I died..(told you)
*reading* well we know is that he died of cardiac arrest
my guess is that is caused by SCP 895
although it's never been observed affecting video equipment from this far before
Further testing is needed to determine whether
SCP 895's red zone is increasing
well
so that's the thing about SCP 8-895 this particular SCP doesn't affect people
that are physically rounded but only affects people that are watching it
through video streams
and I don't know why but that doesn't bode well in the
age of live streams that we're currently in right now so let's low back into this
hopefully-oh good! it loads so quickly
so...
you can actually turn this off which is smart because then you're not looking at it
and you're not going to die and previously
i believe the last time that I played this which is a long time ago
I mistakenly identified that-
as a-
radical Larry's place of origin which I don't want to be it right now
so.. we're in a bit of a pickle we've got a lot of areas
that are closed off to us
but we did manage to save
which is good
so long as we do not DiE a horrible horrible death
so it should be okay
Hanner Hanner Hanner ok
and I know a lot of you guys wanted me to pick up this goddamn
not you Emily Rose do I even need that droppin' that
I can come back if I need to get it
and  I don't think I need this anymore
because I've got a WAY better one in my pocket right now
so if i go over here
and I grab this
"if you ring it he will come"
I WANNA RING IT!
*the death bell bing bongs*
BING BONG
SPLING SPLONG!
Bing bong bring it on!
I don't know if you improved this in any way
but it wasn't very intimidating last time
*bells ding dongs*
Bing bong!
bing-bong bring it on!?
oo hello, bing bonggg
*mark continues to ring death bell*
bing bong-whoa
*death bell echos*
Woaaa
ohhh
*markiplier continues to summon his own funeral*
Bing booong!
*Billy makes Mark's dream of death come true* ahh HEYYYY
fffffffffff *deflating balloon?*
FUCKing fuck you!
fucking fuck you man Jesus
I was Bing bonging somebody else
and then you came
stip stepping in my way
fine
alright let's not do this let's turn this OfF
contain that thing down
I don't know what that's all about but..
time to go get another bing bonger and then bring on another monstrosity
when it wants to play a little nicer for me
so what we got to do is we got to close up the doors behind us
like we were going to do but then NOT leave doors open everywhere for Billy
alright let's drop this
let's drop this
and let's see with this thing doEs
*rings bell*
bing-bong
bing-booooong
*rings again*
Bing bong
anybody here bing bong?
*bing bongs*
*voice crack* bing bing bong bong
bing bong?
*bing bongs*
Bing bong, whoa stop that
I hate that
hey come on
bing-bong?
*le bing and le bong*
Oh i see how this is, okay
close that behind me
close
this one?
whoa
BING BONG *bell bing bongs*
uh no
Seems like i might be doing some bad stuff
BIng BOng
*bing bongs once more*
Bing bong
*loud static sound and mark screams*
fuck you
fuck you *rings bell*
alright okay alright
Alright okay
cause I remember
the last time that I tried to do this it didn't kill me
which was was weird *binga bongs bell* right
God in heaven no that's not what I'm looking for
i'm looking for the SCP note about this thing
Because i forget what it actually does like
I honestly have no idea
all i know is that i really like the bong bing it
I'm gonna splng slong it as much as I can
*rings bell*
bing bong
Bing bong?
*bell sling shlongs 3 times*
Bing
bong
(mark?)
bing
bong
bing (help this man)
Biiing
Okay 096 is nearby
But 173 seems to have fucked off
I don't know what this bing-bong Bell does
and i think i'm gonna be lost about that for a while so
so what i gotta do is I got to find a way to go through heavy containment
because if I can find a way through heavy containment that'll actually be good for me because I need to unlock it first but
that's the only way that I can proOoOoOo
Bing bong?
are you part of this?
are you part of this, huh?
oh..
bing bong?! *bell bing bongs due to mark*
what is that
whoa
oh shit alright
OH kay
well this is good i think
good thing i got this
I lika this I didn't even know this was thre
alrighty then well...
I don't know if this helps if I'm gonna see something in the darkness that I'm not gonna like
oh well we got we gotta cry
boy over here somewhere we got a lot of
doors open over here which I don't like
hey radical Larry shut the fuck up
goddammit goddammit goddammit fuck off
so many open doors not good not good not
good not good why don't I get lost mash
shit I'm over here maybe I could try to
contain him shit so he's coming after me
into his own containment area which
might means that I'm able to contain him
which I don't know if I'm gonna want to
save doing that because I'm bang bong to
bling blong no no we'll see all right
come on how about what you got where am
I going
no boy that ain't good I ain't good how
do i do this i forget i got a torture
someone inside of it don't I isn't that
the whole deal he's attracted to people
in pain for some reason fucking weirdo
whoa oh oh oh oh that ain't good vatika
that I got that a good g JJ JJ JJ you
gotta connect power or something how do
you do this again oh here we go uh-huh
the mountain whoa what the fuck is it
laughing okay I got turned that off and
then I gotta do this I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna save just yet just in case i
do uh not do that there we go
I don't know I can't add this vain idea
that I was going to trap Radical Larry
I hope the whole complex can't hear
that because that oh thank you something
oh so he's in there now because now I
gotta reboot vent plan and now we've
contained right right right that's how
it works right I think anyway oh oh whoa
whoa I can't thank you god damn it you
asshole I fine you like fuck you fuck
you buddy fuck you buddy fuck you buddy
I contained you ruined my one chance of
that you know and I might as well go
into a shadow dimension because I'm
probably gonna die from the cowbell I
want to make sure and I want a second
crack at that one hello hi hello no boy
here we go what kind of world of madness
of Y entering now a bad one I know that
I know that for a fact the bad one I
don't know if there's been any changes
to this area am I in the area oh I can't
see shit I'm still waking up am let me
blink this out of my eyes Hey ah good
well I've got night vision goggles which
is going to help me see which paths are
bad for me good ok this way Oh at that
counter wumpus that's all wampie whoo
people you make our way out of here in
whatever horrible month
shut yo way okay then well these all
lead the wondrous places yeesh I guess
it looked this way well bring your faint
screaming in the distance I bet I do
it'll get here whoo well that looks bad
I'm not gonna go near that one all right
away grilled it would be great if I
wasn't walking with my head tilted like
this now let's see if we can go buy this
thing now can I see it oh that's what it
was doing oh ok just making a figure
eight pattern like go now and let me
wait a second whoo I just gonna stop
here oh nice okay I think we made it
goody goody gum drops that's why what what
what oh come on alright that's fine
that's fine it's fine okay we're coming
back into it now we're not gonna get the
bell because I don't want to bing bong
bring that on I want a bing bong leave
that the fuck alone and then hopefully
not die when scp-173 decides to rear its
fuck ugly head I believe oh maybe I should go
down oh whoa who do you talking about
here are you talking about huh wait you
hitting me what why why were you hey
fuck you man this elevators for sharing
oh well this ain't good i'm bleeding
profusely because i'm being slapped to
death by an unfriendly ghost, ghost dickster
over here keeps slapping me up side the
head
fuck this guy this isn't one of those
cool ghosts you could feel something
near you but you're unable to see it
perhaps if time is now don't know what
that means I keep getting slapped oh I
feel something here well that's weird I'm gonna
go get the night vision goggles once it
kills me and I start over again I'll just load
the game would that have shown up on my
radar like would that would that have
actually showed up on my navigator
because it would have liked that would
have made a lot of sense right cuz it's an
SCP that's slapping me in the darkness
but I gotta go get the night vision
goggles first before I do that and then
I should be okay okay okay oh whoa whoa
whoa whoa away ok ok ok ok ok oh oh that
is not okay oh that is so not OK oh that
is a hundred percent not okay oh my god
oh fuck you dude oh fuck you what do I
do about you fuck he just wants to
return to that elevator fuck alrighty
then you just keep going you keep going
fuck you dude fuck you dude ok so I'm
gonna just ignore him for now close to
go ah right behind me and he likes to stab
me with his claw hands oh this is where
nine tailed fox comes in and shoots
everybody are you in here here ok so I'm
gonna go down this elevator I'm gonna
see if I survive
I don't think I'm gonna but I'm gonna
try real hard okay what the fuck just
happened where ama I oh no no no no no none of that
none of that please none of that no none
of that oh ok shit i don't like is that oh I
don't like this one bit oh boy no it's
that guy but now it is home turf fuck pop out
of that room I know he is like
gangbusters bitch okay elevator power
feed level for card don't need it so like
a save monitor here no course there isn't and fuck
he's out of here errr on oh boy oh boy oh hi
zombie ugh okay what do I do about this
elevator power feed generator ok just stay away
from me buddy just stay away from me nnnnno
no no no you do not
oh I'm gonna put on my gas mask and
I'm gonna breathe so easy around you ohh ohh ohh
i want to go in there but I don't I want
it but I really don't okay all can't see
shit whoa boy okay elevator good good yes
yes please play oh fuck me run run run
run run run run run run oh shitty dicks
shit my dicks fuck me dude fuck that fuck
you dude oh fuck me oh fuck oh fuck come
on now would be the time thank you thank
you thank you dick ugh ugh
all right anyway oh man that was a
fruitless adventure fuck me fuck that
fuck me okay I'm gonna go back in here
I'm gonna try this again i guess i can
save though before i do someone do that
try to contain this asshole fuck you
save hi so I'm going to turn on the
audio feed shoop femur breaker give
him the old one-two femur break oh
sorry oh shit I forgot about this off okay
hopefully that works why I don't know
stop complaining to get contained go to
Radical Larry's fun house of horrors where
you want to be It's where everybody wants
to be
okay all right okay where ya at? Where ya at boo?
where ya at buddy boo? Ah there he is
ok i'm gonna go for now feed can
turn the audio feed off so i'm just
gonna assume though that he got
contained what the fuck was that
you guys see that yeah i don't like this at
all is he contained though let me go
down and double check but I think I got
him whoa well fuck you well shit I
think I got him holy shit I got him oh
my god I got him good for me okay cool
that's great okay I got him yay I got
him so that means that he is never gonna
be a problem again holy shit I did that
okay so i'ma save there and then I'm
going to end this episode but I want to do
more this because there's a lot of new
stuff in here that I want to explore a lot of
improvements a lot of changes and again
developers you deserve something for
this god it so good undertow games
you're just awesome so thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
everybody who has developed this game
so far and thank you to everybody that's
supported it I want to do a few more
episodes and let me know what you think
down in the comments below and as always I
will see you in the next video buh bye